it's a good story my brother AJ and my  mom went out to dinner the other night  and they called ahead to the Mexican  restaurant they said we're gonna be  there 8:30 great boom boom they get  there  and AJ walks up and they say it's gonna  be another 40 minutes and they were on a  tight schedule so AJ takes out his phone  and starts I think he was gonna text me  because I think we had a meeting on the  back end but the hostess freaked out ran  to the back got the owner and AJ and mom  were sitting down in two minutes  now I'm telling you this because I want  you to use this move because it's  tremendous but what I think is  fascinating is the cultural shift the  fact that she was scared he was gonna  negative review on Yelp or tweet out is  very fascinating and is very telling and  more imporantly I'm not joking use that  move it's [ __ ] butter smooth